[Music]
I'm with her
hello I am Eric Davis with the crew from
Aleta battle angel we have producer Jon
Landau director Robert Rodriguez and the
stars Rosa Salazar kyun Johnson hello so
yeah so I actually was lucky enough to
be a trouble maker and saw some of the
footage of the film and it looks awesome
and so let's start you know Jon I'll ask
you this is a projects been simmering
for many years and I'm curious about why
now why is right now the right time to
make a Lita battle angel movie well
right now it was the right time because
this is about a girl who becomes a woman
and takes action it is so right for the
time it is a hero's journey but a
relatable hero she doesn't come into
this world with with superpowers she
comes in not knowing anything about
herself and it's a journey of
self-discovery and along the way she
thinks of herself at first it's an
insignificant girl but she realizes even
she has the ability to make a difference
and I think that's an important message
for everybody no Robert when at what
point because you go way back with James
cab this was originally a James Cameron
he was gonna direct it
he was very heavily involved you go way
back with him yes and so for desperado
at what point were you like let me take
a crack at Aleta and let's I never
thought that was a possibility he's like
Quentin in that way they don't write
scripts for other people to director
there for them to direct and I'd always
seen him attached to this project and
when I first saw it announced that he
had gotten the rights back in 1999 I
purposely stayed away from the material
so I wouldn't know how it ends or what
the story is I wanted to go in fresh so
I was only out of just a conversation of
me just being curious fan when he said
he was going to be just concentrate on
avatars I thought well what happens to
I've been waiting forever for like a
lead a battle angel wouldn't Zek not
getting baiting us no it doesn't
unless if you figure out the script you
can take it you can do it because we've
been looking for things to work with on
together for years and so took it home
looked at it and it was all there I mean
he never got a chance to finish editing
it down he'd written a draft he'd
written six hundred pages of notes and
it just all the characters spoke to me I
identified with Leda identified with a
Hugo character identified with a father
figure and it that's just his magic is
he can find a way to make a story very
Universal very universal themes and then
at spectacle and then add you know Jim
Cameron level world building but it
starts from place of the heart and I
just said man what do I have to do to
work on this thing and he said ready
take it let's go now so Rosa I I know
you were telling a story last night
Robert about watching her audition and
how it brought tears to your eyes and to
your wife and I want to know about what
was this audition and how did it how did
it play out and so from your perspective
well it was a very small room and I
walked in and there was an electric
chemistry right off right off the bat we
said hi and we both like hi and we were
like buzzing with electricity we're both
that kind of creative and and I just I
have a viewpoint on auditions where it's
it's like a two minute play starring me
and I just with the phenomenal sides
that were written by James Cameron you
just could you could create something a
small performance and I just got really
invested and then and then he was really
in it and we were just so in it and and
we both cried yeah
and then when she left I went back and
watched its ape say well maybe there was
just something in the room because maybe
sometimes somebody has a very strong
power in a room and it doesn't translate
to the table you know which is very
important it's almost more important to
be good on tape than in person because
people it's not theater people are gonna
see it on tape so it was there too then
I send it to Jim and he was crying and
it's like and I think it's because of
that also what she just said it was a
play starring her and she gave it all of
her power and all the restraint that she
does that even when she's not on camera
and she was feeding the other actor
their line she's in it in a way that is
purely alina she was that character and
you don't always get that you know you
always hope the character just walks in
the room the perfect person to play it
it happened this time and when that
happens you just got it double down on
that go with us let's go yeah she was
she's just that person and I I just want
to send a message to all of the young
girls out there that you can make grown
men cry I just want you to know that you
can bring them to tears is he identify
with the humanity in it you know it has
nothing to do with gender it's about
it's like I I can feel where she's
coming from I can see the sense of her
being lost in this world and finding her
power and you see her overcome and
that's you know you all want that for
your life yeah okay and how did you get
involved teleforce well tell us about
your character and also how you got
involved in the film yeah well to start
out how I got involved I auditioned I
think I went in for a casting associate
office said untitled James Cameron
Robert Rodriguez I was like wow okay
like that's big one so I go in I go in
for the audition and shred and left and
that was it and then a few months later
I heard that Robert wanted to meet with
me and I went into the room and met with
him and did one audition and I was like
wow that was incredible I left I was
like regardless of what happened you
know what that was such an incredible
time you know I think that was my very
first Directors meeting like I had never
met director before and then I met with
him again and I was like okay I might
actually have a shot at this thing and
then when I went to test I just felt so
comfortable on the set and it just felt
so right and then I was lucky enough to
get a call and Robert sent me an email
with
it just that subject was just guess what
and there was just a picture of the
manga script of me my character Hugo
kissing elitist character and then I was
like all right and then I later I was on
set and working with you know the best
actors and best director and best writer
in the world so it was such an
incredible
I mean whirlwind you know from from
going from you know working on TV here
and there to working on one of the
biggest movies being shot I mean I guess
ever tried to cast like a cool character
I think I was supposed to be the cool
guy in the movie cuz I wanna send an
actor who come in and they're playing
cool this guy just was cool yeah I had
this long hair man and he was just so
unassuming and he was like hey I'd want
to be that guy and if I was in that town
I'd be looking up to that guy but it's
and it's not an acted thing it's like
something that just comes naturally and
so that's just really hard to create you
kind of kind of have to be that guy and
what was it like making this movie at
troublemaker I just imagine most of it
or all that was shot was shot there in
Austin and out like away from Hollywood
like what's that process like and and
how is it different from a traditional
movie like in Hollywood well it was the
most beautiful drive to work every
single day driving around Texas and and
driving out there's a big haul of trees
and you show up and you see the city
behind and it's just it's gorgeous every
every hour of the day it's just
beautiful and we we used a lot of that
Texas light yeah and that's it hurry
there's a lot of artists here who are
working on a movie of this scale yeah
for the first time so if they're not
jaded at all by oh it's another big
movie it's more like they really want it
they really want to prove themselves so
that attitude that electricity really
translates to everything you see it in
the sets you see it in the in the design
you see it in the crew you see
everyone's faces whether as they're
making something really special and and
it really investing in it and it's not
like there'll be another gig like this
next month it's like this is a
once-in-a-lifetime chance everyone had
that I like that energy I like that and
I think what Roberts crew brought to the
table was not just a technical level of
proficiency whether it be a design or
construction but they brought a passion
and I think that was infectious among
everybody the pride they took and what
they were working on and what they were
creating creating really made for a
great environment yeah and a lot of them
had been working with Robert for the
last 15 years more and and you could it
was a well-oiled machine a happy machine
that's cool all right so I want to do a
little rapid-fire this or that from with
the movie-going experience because
that's my big thing and so in theaters
or at home I have a feeling I know the
answer to this one but 2d or 3d I mean
you're working with Cameron on this and
there's a 3d push the limits of what
we've seen before like well you know
movies now surprisingly that a lot of
most of the 3d movies are converted now
this is we shoot with the big double rig
and it's a different thing it's a more
it's a real 3d and you can tell the
difference I mean when you watch it
people go the 3ds amazing well because
it was actually shot dude okay well that
makes sense well you wanted to use sorry
you have to use 3d monitors as well so
there's points well there's points when
you know I would be getting off there
was a point where I get off a motorcycle
it's in the trailer getting on the
motorcycle and you know pulling out and
Roberts like hey come into the video
village really quickly and I go in he's
like here put the 3d glasses on then he
puts on some like epic music I'm
watching playback in 3d getting on the
motorcycle and it's just like you're
there you already feel like you're
watching the movie before all the
effects have gone through we had like
three huge houses where it was like
having three actual film crews we had
Wetty we had everyone from the digital
effects side we had the 3d people we had
Belle Pope we had you know just a normal
film crew
it was it was huge we were a big family
and the other thing about 3d Robert
actually filmed a feature film in 3d
before Jim did because he did spike its
383 before Jim we had before we have an
avatar and he used Jim's camera system
so so Robert brings a familiarity with
3d and understanding that 3d is not a
gimmick 3d is is about creating a more
engaging experience an immersive
experience like it's a window into a
world not a world coming out of a window
and that's I think would be very sad
alright so popcorn candy Raisinets candy
in popcorn popcorn oh right this one
says a lot about who you are as person
Twizzlers or Redbox whistlers yes oh my
gosh
well he gave it away yes he's not gonna
be like he makes a lot of traffic snacks
chocolates in the shapes of skulls you
open it there's like another chocolate
melting in there it's crazy
hugo takes a widow his gyro bike to
taste chocolate for the first time and
she picks up just by Robert Amanda
chocolate city chocolate no I was like I
had committed to doing it then it's like
the night before filming oh my gosh I
gotta make I had like six every take I
was idiot they were like Rosa don't eat
it and I was like okay
[Music]
of the
[Music]